any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
welcome everybody to this episode of the
arthur c clarke Center for human
imaginations into the impossible podcast
I'm your host ever fearful Bryan Keating
and today it's quite a treat to be
joined by first-time author and a
longtime reporter chase Purdy and the
first thing I want to ask you is I grew
up in Purdy's New York you have any
relation to the Purdy's of New York I
don't know I doubt it because I am from
the Purdy's of Louisville Kentucky's
okay
you might have made it made it out there
who knows you might be have some some
DNA still in Purdy's New York and if not
you could just go there and say it's
your town straw that chases a reporter
who has written a wonderful new book
which I devoured no pun intended called
billion-dollar burger and it's the story
of a new type of technology that has
potential to both do well and do good
and that and that is you know the quest
for artificial or synthetic or lab-grown
meat and and the experiences as I've
described the book before we started
talking about recording rather is sort
of it's sort of like a diary mixed with
investigative journalism mixed with a
you know an article that you might find
or you know a treatment that you'd find
in the top Business Journal so chase
first of all welcome to the into the
impossible podcast where are you
currently located thanks for having me I
am currently still in sort of
self-imposed quarantine in Brooklyn New
York you can tell it's very hot in this
apartment everything warm out there I
just did a podcast with folks out in
Long Island where I'm from originally
before perdy so I was on the line and
yeah they said if said the 80s out there
so you know we have to deal with this
weather behind me at the South Pole it's
in the low negative 80s there so it's a
hundred two hundred degrees cold so I
wanted to have you on there ever since I
found out about this book coming out
because as I said we focus here in the
arthur c clarke center on the future of
all things relate to humanity
and one of those things of course is our
sustenance as human beings it's one of
the things that makes us human so I want
to read just a quick blurb about the
book which the full title is billion
dollar burger inside Big Tex race for
the future of food
it's been called fascinating and
relevant to timely issues like
environmental sustainability and global
food systems and kind of the extended
quote about it is how this band of dr.
scientists activists and entrepreneurs
have been racing to end animal
agriculture as we know it helping to
fulfill a dream of creating meat without
ever having to kill an animal in the
laboratories of Silicon Valley companies
and Dutch universities visionaries are
growing burgers and steaks from
microscopic animal cells and inventing
systems to do so at scale allowing us to
feed the world without slaughter and
environmental devastation so the first
thing I always like to ask authors we
have a lot of authors who come on the
show the first thing I always ask is
unlike the advice I always judge books
by their covers and I'd like to know how
did you come up with the cover idea
how'd you come up with the title the
subtitle give us the the inside baseball
burger baseball story of how did you
come up with the title and uncover it
well I really first have to credit a
friend for the working title and working
cover that we were playing with the
working title of this was the end of
meat and sort of the abstract cover idea
was like the end of meat over sort of
this graphic of an upside down pig you
know but the more that we started
talking about this on the editorial
level and that's my friends you know
this really wasn't about the end of meat
this is sort of about a continuation or
the evolution of meat and so the end of
meat never really would have fit
ultimately we knew that like we wanted
to have sort of like as a simple sort of
cover we knew that we wanted to really
hit on the fact that I mean one of the
things I've been thinking about a lot
through my conversations is that I've
been reporting on the subject has been
that
even if a person is uncomfortable with
the idea of cell cultured meat there is
enough money and interest behind it that
it is going to be something that you
have to be confronted with at some point
or another and you know this is the
result of basically you have like
literal billionaires who are putting
money in this you have you know millions
and millions of dollars going into this
I mean basically the idea is that's a it
could disrupt like this multi-billion
dollar industry even that's sort of the
goal 1.7 trillion dollar industry
actually and we really wanted to get
across people who would pick this up is
that this is like a this is something
that could be like this massive
disrupter and what better way than to
sort of wrap in the fact that
billionaires are interested that it's
going to challenge like a multi-billion
dollar industry then to sort of get on
the cover this like billion-dollar
burger and the idea of the graphics
behind it which is just sort of two
burger buns with sort of some molecular
sort of graphics or you know penis a
burger buns yes is sure to communicate I
think it's sort of obviously like this
is really you know sort of heavy-duty
science stuff that's going into this and
like this is sort of like a reimagine a
ssin of like what where you're used to
in the connection the technology
obviously is not to be really overlooked
I think it's it's it's sort of
interesting this confluence that I
thought about I lived in the Bay Area in
Silicon Valley for only about a year but
I'm pretty familiar with the culture
we've had on a lot of innovators and
people from Silicon Valley and you know
to a person either I don't think that
there's anyone who's opposed to this
project and it's sort of unique in
Silicon Valley I mean you can think
about all this stuff I had on Sarah
fryer who wrote no filter which is the
inside story of Instagram and how that's
you know kind of been called the social
network you know of Instagram that
equivalent type of a book and she is not
you know she doesn't spare the criticism
that has come about from
technology of social media whether it's
people you know putting their spotty
cert you know plastic surgery on
Instagram or bullying and these clicks
of children and how Instagram can be
abused but you know the first thing that
I started thinking about that is and
maybe I'm wrong but it seems like this
only has upside I don't just mean the
financial I mean the lack of you know of
using animals to provide this this meat
of the impact on the environment the
impact really may be ethically and and
certainly now I highlighted more than
ever and I want to hear your take on
this bike Ovid which has really been
traced and enlarged in some part I
should say to these slaughterhouses and
the outbreaks in there so first rambling
a little bit but I'd like to know does
this have any downsides except for you
know people might lose money and that's
just the nature of our capitalist
economy but is her downside to it in
your opinion you know I think that this
really hits on like a fascinating
element of something that I figure it
out as I started really digging into
this space is that there is a divide
when you talk to the entrepreneurs and
the innovators who are behind this is
that when you talk to them about sell
filtered meet some of them referred to
it as technology and some of them refer
to it as food hmm and I think that one
of the things that sort of really
separates this from like an Instagram or
social media and Silicon Valley is that
food is an incredibly emotional
incredibly political incredibly personal
thing that we interact with every every
single person no matter how much money
you have you know that could like sort
of change what kinds of foods you can
eat but we all eat the same way it goes
through the same goes through the same
orifice in our barn where billionaire
old hardware and and for that reason I
think that you're gonna find some people
saying like oh there is a downside I
think that you would talk to not very
far out of Silicon Valley herself Alice
Waters who would say that we're getting
way too far from nature and that in
doing this you
you sort of think that you sort of you
know we're almost challenging nature in
some way that like we can do better
hmm and I think for people who come from
that perspective I think that this is a
downside that this is sort of the
granddaddy of processed foods in in some
way and we've seen what processed foods
not a fair comparison but like you know
pop-tarts haven't really done that much
for the for our health and it's also a
super processed food so I think that you
can really start diving into lots of
conversations around what this means in
like an emotional level or unless with a
natural level that like poses lots of
big questions about whether this has a
downside or not but to the things that
you brought up the impact on climate
change the how this could really mean
kovat 19 is an excellent example I think
that in fact I think koban 19 is sort of
a horrible gift that now this these this
sort of nascent industry has if you
think about before this virus and then
this pandemic sort of set in when you
read about cell cultured meat if you
read about it you probably mostly heard
two things it's it's gonna be so much
much better when it comes to like sort
of the effort to combat climate change
and it's going to result in killing a
lot fewer animals and those are huge
upsides what koban 19 has done is it has
exposed at least especially in the u.s.
that the u.s. meat system is fraught
with problems I mean think about it has
exposed to us the more about the labor
conditions inside the meatpacking plants
and how tightly packed everything still
is because we don't use robots to tear
apart carcasses that come down the
assembly line because they're all
different shapes and sizes
we still need humans to do this and
they're shoulder to shoulder doing the
nitty gritty hard work of packaging of
ripping apart and packaging our meat for
us and I think that this has unveiled
for us or in a very real way
maybe you aren't that far off from where
we were in the jungle when upton
sinclair wrote his famous book i think
that it sort of shows the weakness of
having this hyper consolidated meat
system where a very tiny handful of
companies and a very tiny handful of
factories are responsible for putting
out 85 percent of our meat that way if
you have a nine meatpacking plant shut
down suddenly 25 percent of the meat
supply is impacted mmm and so suddenly i
think that you can these industry groups
can are sorry these these sort of south
cultured meat startups are suddenly
going to be able to seize on all of
these very real downsides in the current
meat system which have resulted in
higher meat prices which have resulted
in CEOs with Smithfield and Tyson saying
oh my gosh like we all better prepare
this could be bad for our meat supply
there could be shortages and I think
that um you know in addition to all the
climate climate related upsides you know
we're now seeing some new upsides yeah
so one of our guests recently Peter
Diamandis who is known for he's I call
him the most optimistic pessimist or the
most pessimistic optimist but he talks
about these six exponential DS are the
six DS of the exponential growth and one
of those is as disruptive and and and
this applied when I have a conversation
with Sarah fryer about Instagram or book
no filter and that's how you know
companies like Kodak and and other
companies really didn't see this coming
and I wonder you know for these Tysons
and these other companies besides
obviously they're gonna lobby and
they're gonna try to stay in trench do
you see opportunities for these
companies that are actually the
traditional you know far far more you
know kind of slaughterhouse etcetera
meat packaging industries of today to
benefit or are they just gonna do what
Kodak did and then lose this this
overall battle for you know what could
be doing well while doing good yeah I
think that's a really interesting
question and I think that you know it's
been a decent amount of time in the book
I think looking back at some of the food
fights in America and you just you know
for listeners you know one of the early
who'd flights that actually led to the
creation of the dairy Lobby was the the
butter the butter people being so
threatened by the arrival of margarine
that they just went bonkers and state
state houses across this country and
including and in Washington you try to
get legislation passed that would
basically you know legislate margin out
of existence I think that we see it
today whenever we see the dairy industry
again like feeling so threatened by
plant-based milks that they are like
doing everything they can and they
failed so far in the Jews and the
judiciary but they're doing everything
they can now is the legislative branch
to like basically make it so that you
can't call almond milk milk because
consumers are just going to be so
confused and I think that the meat
people have learned some of them at
least a little bit from that and I think
that's evident from high-profile
appearances that CEOs of big meat
companies have made where they'd used
language that kind of shows it I think
it was Tom Hayes with is the former CEO
of Tyson appeared on like Fox Business a
year and a year year and a half ago and
he started using language where he
basically specifically said like oh
we're not a meat company anymore we're a
protein company because they see that
there is interest in plant-based protein
they see that there could be interest in
cell culture protein they see that there
is still interest in animal-based
protein and the fact that these big
companies that have always identified as
meat companies are now calling
themselves protein companies signals to
me that they see almost like the writing
on the wall that there are future foods
out there that people are very curious
about them and eager to try them and I
think that cell cultured meat is one of
those foods and will be one of those
foods and you know this would still be a
tough thing to attain but analysts
Rabobank we know when you ask them about
this they would say it would only take
sort of this
alternatives seizing 5% of the total
market share to sort of basically a
million yeah yeah it would be a major
disruption yeah and when you another
question that kind of parallel to me
this notion of Silicon Valley startup
that runs throughout this book obviously
throughout Sarah's book as well is this
notion of first mover advantage and
whether or not there really will be a
you know such a thing that will take
place for that some of the companies
that you talk about I'm showing one now
behind me now this just meet which this
doesn't exist right you cannot buy the
pack of chicken that I'm showing here I
believe right yes yeah that's sort of a
sort of a wishful or not wishful
thinking but aspirational I'll say this
is from The Guardian article not too
long ago do you see the parallels there
with say you know a Facebook or
something like that where maybe they
won't be the the first company to
actually get somewhere won't be the one
that makes the breakthrough but you know
one of the first companies will
breakthrough and then they'll basically
put up a barrier that's insurmountable
in other words will there be a maybe a
second mover advantage loosely speaking
or do you think that now there'll be a
wide-open spectrum of different
alternatives and I mean there's only so
many different flavors of traditional
foods and the old joke is you know what
do you cook what do you you know what
does something taste like if it's not
exotic you know it tastes like chicken
so I mean there's chicken there's duck
you spend a lot of time talking to talk
and pate and yeah there's all sorts of
those but there's only so many different
things that they're gonna try to imitate
or simulate do you see there being this
kind of first mover advantage with just
a couple companies will stake it out and
the rest will be fighting over you know
the jerky market or something I don't
know I think that is you know that's
really kind of this what goes into this
products are so complex that it's hard
for me to imagine there being I mean
like yes there's obviously gonna be you
know the first movers are going to get a
lot of they they're gonna be the ones
who really drag into the public
imagination the possibilities and sort
of normalize more the idea of cultured
meat and I think that's a massive role
it's hugely important and I think that
if people are receptive that there's a
lot of money
it then goes to these early companies to
be better and get better at what they do
but I do think also that um you know I
spend a little bit of time in the book
talking about this but the initial meets
that we're going to see are going to be
meets that are what we would call today
processed meats chicken nuggets burgers
meatballs chicken tenders things that
you know I mean I really hate to put it
this way and I don't want to confuse
people this is not a perfect analogy at
all but if you think remember that all
the news stories and controversy around
pink slime yeah that came out many years
back it's basically like a lot of the
when you pull subculture meat out of
like the bioreactor this earlier stage
stuff it's really like malleable it's it
can be shaped into like nuggets it can
be shaped into meatballs like we round
beef basically mm-hmm and so for those
products that's gonna be the first wave
and some companies particularly one in
Israel I love arms as basically said you
know what like we're not gonna be a
first wave company we're gonna focus on
the really hard task of doing like the
really advanced work of figuring out how
to grow like a full cut a steak for
instance that has like you know a I mean
think about a chicken breast is a good
example you pulled one or chicken nugget
you kind of see that it's like solid but
you know it's kind of contained within
like the fried part of the Nugget you
pull apart a chicken breast and you
start to notice oh this is actually kind
of stringy mm-hmm getting cells to grow
and that like stringy structure is very
difficult it's not an easy thing to do
and that gets even more advanced
whenever you're talking about a
different species like a like a cow and
so some companies will be in that second
wave but those products that they bring
to the market
be those like cuts that you can really
work with and I think that they have a
lot they have a lot to gain to once they
get to the market mmm
so yes there will be an advantage for
first movers but there'll also be a
second wave and maybe even a third wave
when we're talking about Crustacea we're
talking about fish you know it's I think
that's sort of a wide-open field of
opportunity for for these companies that
are out there now I want a 1x4 either
growing kangaroo in Australia even if
it's kamek yeah I mean I'm I'm Jewish
I'm not I'm not
ultra Orthodox but I keep kosher etc you
know just thinking about all these
exotic you know things you could have
you know a bobster that's perfectly
kosher you know depending on what
ingredients go into it I want to first
take a step back and talk about the
science behind it because it is a it is
we have a very tech minded audience but
we're we love to mirror it out so I've
got an image here from a paper that I'm
linking in the show notes how soft
cultured meat is actually created can
you spend a little bit of time I know
you're not a scientist necessarily but
you take a little bit of time to explain
like what aspect of this most it out to
you because when I see it I'm like wow
you know this all happens naturally and
it comes out delicious but you know
maybe that's because of our taste buds
you know it's it's either the receptor
or the producer and we have are just
wired for it take us through the
technology a little bit I know this
isn't you know use first time you're
seeing their image but I think that the
reactions are sort of common and
discussed throughout the book so walk us
through how does it work how does create
how does cultured meat come about well
you basically just need you know then
the simplest level you it's a pretty
simple recipe you need three things you
need cells you need food that those
cells can eat and then helps them
proliferate and you need a controlled
environment sort of controlled and
sterile environment for them to grow in
that can kind of mimic all the
environmental aspects of growth that
they love you know in our and in nature
you know the a cow is basically a
bioreactor it's the walking living
reactor and the blood inside the cow
delivers the nutrients to the cells for
them to sort of grow and and replicate
over and over again so the first thing
is you know you needed to be able to do
a sort of very basic simple biopsy on an
animal to collect cells stem cells or
what you know these scientists really
loved and essentially those cells can
come from any part of the body just
likes to sort of tap the idea that you
can take a cell from the tip of a
feather and you basically can you can a
scientist know how to basically take
these cells and get them to go back into
what's called a pluripotent state which
the way I sort of phrase it in the book
is that you know they're all different
kinds of cells that are responsible for
all different kinds of things some grow
into feathers some grow into muscle
tissue so I'm going to fat tissue some
growing a connective tissue and if you
think about cells working on a
construction site is how I used it is
that you have electricians you have
carpenters you have surveyors and they
all sort of work harmoniously to build
this like bigger structure but it is
possible to take a construction site
worker who's a carpenter and you can
send her back to school and you can
teach her how to do like wiring and all
sorts of like you know electrical stuff
and stick her back out into the
construction site to be an electrician
and the same works for these cells you
can take a cell from the tip of a
feather send it back to school a
pluripotent state and it can choose it's
at the state where it can choose a new
life adventure and maybe that's a muscle
muscle tissue maybe that's to become fat
tissue so the cells then do that so you
give these cells and they need to
basically eat and what they eat is this
liquid medium for a long time this
liquid medium was fetal bovine serum
which is essentially exactly what it
sounds like it's the blood from a cow
fetus which is so rich in nutrients and
is exactly what stem cells really love
to be able to like replicate
no one's using that anymore it's way too
expensive and for the vegans who are
largely behind these companies that they
have sort of ethical concerns with that
and so they're now plant-based mediums
there are synthetic mediums and these
are sort of closely guarded intellectual
property which is bruised full of
nutrients the amino acids the proteins
the everything that you need to get
certain species of cells to grow to grow
into healthy sort of tissue and all of
that happens inside a bioreactor
and there are different kinds of our
reactors but essentially a bioreactor is
a space that maintains a temperature and
pH levels and oxygen levels
it sort of stirs it's able to stir the
liquid medium the liquid around enough
to keep the oxygen like sort of the same
throughout it and it makes these creates
the conditions that over course of like
several days or weeks these cells
proliferate and become you know a fully
formed like clump of tissue basically
and then you centrifuge that bioreactor
and scrape the tissue out and then you
can hand that over to sort of a product
engineer or which is off very often a
chef that's been hired by these
companies to them play with it and
figure out okay we have this real meat
we have the muscle tissue we have the
fat tissue and stick the two together
and what could we make and that's that's
sort of the very simple sort of dumbed
down version of how this happens and
that's when I say dumbed down version I
mean the perversion that I need to work
with whenever I write this stuff because
it's a lot so far over my head yeah it's
incredibly advanced biotechnology you
know and it's being used for as we said
you know the potential both to improve
through disruption as Peter Diamandis
would say both the economy the the
environment and also maybe Ethical
Treatment of Animals so I want to talk a
little bit about you know the side of
things that maybe people don't really
think about we went through the you know
the technology
but how does it compare when we think
about you know existing things that you
can go down that you can't buy these yet
right you can't buy the billion-dollar
burger even if you could afford it all
right 500 yeah they're about $500 I
think the culmination of the book you're
saying it's about $500 how do these
compare with traditional you know vegan
alternatives which I've tried which are
great you know the beyond products
they're delicious and I'm a big time you
know I love eating meat I'm sorry to say
I know in a hundred years when this
podcast is unveiled I'll be canceled etc
but I do eat meat I try to minimize it
and one of the ways I minimize it is
instead of having you know two sausage
links I'll have you know one beyond uh
one beyond possible sausage patty and
then one you know kosher sausage back so
when they taste really good delicious in
fact maybe not super nutritious but but
they don't taste like the other one you
know I'm having two of one burger that's
that's chuck meat and the other one
that's beyond possible tastes good it
doesn't taste the same how do you
contrast these two are I forgot if
you're a vegan or you're you're
semi-vegetarian how do you characterize
yourself I would say that I eat about 90
percent of my diet
95% of is plant-based but I do have meat
from time to time I don't eat pork and
and then I don't eat beef either if I
can I can help up just because it is
like the the biggest contributor so
those people who have tried these
probably on these veggie products here's
some vegetables behind me how do you
characterize how do you distinguish
between them do you agree that they
don't really taste with me or what's
your thought on the existing products we
can go whenever I talk to people about
these products I usually sort of I mean
the the conclusion that they make and
the conclusion that I definitely make is
that you can't really eat these
especially in burger form and like
really truly expected to taste exactly
like you want it to taste if you're
trying to get that exact mimic but it
does like I think that impossible gets
the texture down down
really well I think the Vitesse is kind
of close I think that the nutrition
profile is very very different
my contrast you know what I have tried
you know and these are like sort of
largely fried chicken chicken tenders
chicken salad
duck Therese Oh wah grah I mean they're
the they're the real deal they taste I
mean I think that I mentioned I tried a
chicken tender that Memphis meat made
and I was humbled by the experience not
just from the taste of it and they
presented it with like basically no
seasoning there's a little salt little
pepper but they wanted me to eat this
product without sort of being dressed up
on a burger or anything and and not only
was it taste great but the texture was I
mean pulling it apart and seeing the
stringiness was just a crazy experience
and you know I I think that it comes
down to the fact that this is real fat
tissue this is real muscle tissue this
isn't sort of some plant-based
interloper that's wanting to be this
this is actually the stuff on a real
level a biochemical level and that's
gonna bring about the same taste I think
that they scientists are doing a lot of
work on their own sort of figuring out
like what the ratio of fat and muscle
tissue is because you know most the
taste that we taste comes from like fat
tissue and I think that like you know
those ratios are where like all the
magic kind of goes but um I think
they're hands down much more I mean I
was convincing as the wrong work as
convincing implies that like you know
it's trying to masquerade as something
that it's not and I would argue that it
is real meat and but I mean there's
really no comparison there's no
comparing plant-based in cell culture
yeah I can't really wait to try it if
you talked towards the end of the book
about yeah the scaling of the price
which you know literally was two hundred
and three hundred thirty thousand
dollars back when it debuted in 2013 for
a burger patty and that was about $500
per patty
when is that exponential curve it's
another one of Peters the exponential
trends as yes the ste monetization or
reduction in the cost etc deflationary
pressures that will occur cause of the
disruptive technology when do you
foresee it you know going down to your
local jack-in-the-box or whatever you
guys eat in Brooklyn and picking one up
yeah no you know I think that this is
this this is a great moment to sort of
introduce what the issue is here is that
there is definitely some scientific work
here that still needs to be mastered but
for the simplest products the tech and
science is there and the number one
thing that is absolutely stopping this
from becoming like more widely available
is the regulatory red tape well if you
want to think like the USDA and the FDA
have basically signed a joint agreement
that they're going to share the
responsibility of overseeing cultured
meat production but they still haven't
really laid down in black and white what
sort of the ground rules are what needs
to happen where the checkpoints and as
soon as they sort of give the green
light as soon as some regulatory agency
around the world maybe it'll be in
Singapore first maybe it'll be in the
United Arab Emirates maybe it'll be
Israel but as soon as some regulatory
body somewhere gives the green light the
companies that are in this space are
gonna say like ok now it's very we can
very safely build these production
facilities that are going to be needed
to at scale produce what they can
already make it's a tough sort of cell
to be like let's put in millions of
dollars to build a production facility
and not have you know a regulatory green
light yet so I think that you could see
and a few companies that have a lot of
money just Memphis meets future meat
technologies over in Israel have already
broken ground on their pilot production
facilities and so we're getting really
really really close to that edge where
we will
start seeing it and I do think it'll
probably be like the impossible foods
route with the inaudible burger we're
like they really decided you know let's
make splashy entrances in a different
market at San Francisco New York what's
partner with chefs let's let's drum up
media attention and really sort of like
spark the curiosity bug and people to
want to come out and try it at these
sort of fancier or like high-profile
restaurants and stuff and then
eventually it'll sort of become
something that you can get in retail but
I would not be surprised it'd been a
year people somewhere in the world I
would love for that to be the u.s. just
for myself started to see this as an
option and several restaurants hmm so
the last thing on my list of the
specifics about the book before we get
into a little bit deeper more big
picture things that I like to ask all my
all my guests I want ask you know what
are the kind of unintended consequences
that could come about you talked a lot
in the book about and I love the scenes
where you talk with your mother cuz I
she's just kind of this archetype of a
of the normal quote-unquote person who's
not like you know just born at you know
Texas barbecue and only eats meat I know
some people like that and she's not like
a complete vegan right so she's kind of
this proxy for every every person and I
don't know what do you see is the hurdle
there's there's sort of the that yuck
factor oh there's a a it's grown in a
lab B it's grown from like you know DNA
and you know that could be scary it's
grown in a reactor that has scary
connotations what he's I personally came
away from the book feeling like that
could be one of the hurdles you know
most significant ones where do you see
that and how do you see that being
solved and is there something else I'm
overlooking and missing out that you
actually think is a deeper part of the
story and challenge I think that this is
all gonna ultimately come down to like
how these companies will a how
transparent they are about their
processes and all
how they communicated I mean do you do
you really tout this as like and you're
gonna get back to what we were sort of
what we're saying in the very beginning
which is like you call this a food or
you call it technology do you highlight
the fact that it's like this
technological bright spot to like the
climate change fight or do you highlight
that it's like the process by which you
make it that's like a cultured and a bio
right bioreactor thing or do you
highlight where it comes from
for instance just is the company just
which is featured most heavily in this
book has a deal with a Kobe beef farm
it's in Japan and they are sourcing
cells from sort of Kobe beef cows and
they also have a deal with like this
sort of very well-known rancher who
works with Black Angus cows outside of
San Francisco and do you really
highlight that do you sort of say like
for the first time you can buy Kobe beef
for really cheap because we're using
these like cows that have these really
impressive genetics and we're taking
this genetics and we're democratizing
this this meat that for so long has been
well outside the price range of like you
know your everyday eater how that's
communicated I think is gonna be like
the number one hurdle for people because
like yeah I mean my mom you know one of
the things that Josh Tetrick the CEO of
just asked her is like what's the
biggest thing that's gonna stop people
in Louisville from eating this of course
my mother didn't have a comfortable
being the spokesperson for heaters in
Louisville Kentucky but but she sort of
thought that you know the idea of this
being man-made meat is gonna be the
hurdle and Josh sort of kept thinking
about that throughout the lunch that we
had at his company headquarters is he's
like yeah I wouldn't want to eat man
named meat so it
how do you sort of I guess think this
comes again to like capturing that
public imagination how do you sort of
get people to think about this is it a
fake meek product is it a yeah I mean
that's the tough part and it's sort of
well beyond my paygrade to figure that
out for them but um I think that that's
that's sort of the trick yeah great okay
chase well now we're gonna enter soon
will enter the spin zone the plug zone
where you can plug anything you like
especially the book and your writing but
before I do that I like to ask my
authors especially how they react to to
this quote and this is from mm this is
from the late the late great Carl Sagan
and who I've had his daughter and his
widow on the podcast and and this is
about a famous quote from his from their
and Sasha Sagan's father and durians
a late husband and that's what Carl
Sagan says is that a book is basically
magic it's a way of turning these
squiggles and lines on paper written
perhaps long ago and then printing an
idea into somebody's mind perhaps
millennia later and my question to you
first is or did you always want to write
a book and do you do you feel like this
book is is going to play a role or Ken
has a mission a vision if you will to
play sort of a role that may last long
behind beyond the current moment that
we're in well the answer to the first
part of that question is no I never
imagined myself writing a book I have
always really except so I've been a
journalist since I graduated from
college knows a journalist in college
I've always enjoyed writing but I've
always sort of thought that I've
excelled at really capturing like
emotion and steams and sort of more
shorter and more shorter kind of like
writing a book is super daunting to me
it was I mean
I knew because I reported on the space a
lot I already knew a lot of the people
in advance and outs of it I kind of knew
the major challenges and their players
the biggest themes the biggest questions
and that really helped me but you know
it wasn't an easy process to me the
reporting was fun it took me all over
the world the toughest part for me about
writing a book is trying to like thread
a narrative arc and in this case it was
Josh tetrax story across you know more
than 250 pages that's just not easy to
do especially when his story is very
much in motion I mean like every single
month these companies are making like
moving forward in leaps and bounds and
to try to capture this man's story while
it's evolving was a really tough thing
to do and to stretch out and this isn't
a long history I mean you know the the
the book sort of opens on 2013 we've
only gone 7 years I mean this is sort of
a quick taper through a brief history of
this technology and and so this it was
it was really tough for me to kind of
get into a rhythm but once I did it was
really enjoyable I actually liked the
pacing of writing a book and you know
the biggest thing that I really hoped
for it and one of the things that I
think could make it sort of be relevant
years ahead is the book is inherently
about people who want to create the
change that they want to see it is
ultimately about a man who tried out
different ways to like change the world
and just didn't really find a way that
really worked for him mm-hmm even after
he found this company even after it was
considered like a unicorn and Silicon
Valley he still didn't really quite know
that this was a pen
and now he's kind of settled on this
trajectory that he wants to go after and
he's started up as a vegan activist
whose best friend's was a vegan
activists and in a lot of ways this is a
book about vegan activist to sort of you
know this is sort of a simple way of
putting it but they kind of set down
their buckets of red paint that they
throw on fur coat so fashion shows the
sort of absolutist yelling at the top of
their lungs mentality and the sort of
thought okay there has to be another way
that we can accomplish our goals maybe
let's try to play this like capitalist
system that we see so much that we find
so problematic maybe let's try to
subvert it hmm so let's actually create
these businesses that make these
products that like are the same thing as
as meat and let's try to tackle this
problem from within the actual culture
that we despise so much and I think that
that kind of story of how to be a change
maker is something that is a lesson to
take from this book and the second thing
I would say is that in terms of the so
cultured meat technology this book first
and for I mean I'm optimistic about this
technology I think it's fascinating I'm
eager to see it develop because I think
that the implications are potentially
huge but this book I think does tell
people or does sort of suggest people at
least that it's gonna be really
important to hold these companies to
account what they're are proposing is
huge they want to replace a system of a
way that we've been eating meat for a
very very very very very very long time
and that comes with a lot of
responsibility it comes with the need to
be transparent it comes with a need for
us as consumers to be really thoughtful
about what we expect from them and and I
hope that that's a take away too is that
we continue to be thoughtful and
skeptical about these companies because
they deserve our skepticism and our
thoughtfulness yeah let segues perfectly
into my next question which is if you
had to choose between the audience for
this reader readership audience for the
look would you rather it be red if he
could only give it to one would you
rather give it to a skeptic hater on
these types of alternatives to me or
someone who's already a fanboy fangirl I
would give it to a skeptic hands-down I
mean my mom was a skeptic whenever she I
mean we didn't really even talk much
about this topic as I was reporting it
because I just sort of knew where she
stood
she was very creeped out by the idea and
so then it was all the more fun to watch
her react in the book whenever we went
to we flew our across the country and we
went to just headquarters and she had to
sit down and be confronted with the very
thing that made her uncomfortable
mm-hmm and so I think that it's far more
interesting to watch a skeptic work
through everything in their mind than it
is to you know hand it out to a fanboy
all right great
and the last question that I like to ask
my guests especially those that have
written books because as I said you know
books are kind of these time capsules
that last for a long time you're
familiar with probably our namesake
arthur c clarke and his famous book 2001
which turned into a Space Odyssey by
Stanley Kubrick
and some of the scenes in that revolve
around this giant monolith this enormous
object whose purpose is not exactly
clear but in the books it represents a
sort of a time capsule perhaps a warning
a message delivery a device you know
this is before USB keys and and you
could have email I suppose so if if
chase party were designing a time
capsule that had the last a billion
years what would you put in it or on it
what would it say or do or represent for
a billionaire long project any time
people talk about time capsules or I'm
always gravitated I think toward um the
idea that music is something that we
sort
pass down or sort of hand off to like
someone so far down the road and it's
not a single thing per se but I think
that if I had to stick something in a
time capsule it would probably be the
complete works of Stephen Sondheim who I
think I think he composes music that's
so complex and sophisticated and really
explores in no sort of simple way the
human experience this like relationship
between people and art between spouses
with the self between parents and
children love and loss and bivolo and
passion and like so so so much more and
I feel like every time I listen to
Sondheim I always end up learning a
little bit something new about myself
some contour of myself or something that
makes me feel and parently like more
empathetic and appreciative of like the
beauty and the layers of the world
around me mm-hmm and it's just like
really singular music compared to
everything else that you're hearing
whether it's musical theater or like
other sort of composition I think
Stephen Sondheim is incredible and I
think that he his work should absolutely
be heard like a trillion years from now
well chase birdie I hope your book will
be read maybe not for a trillion years
but I hope it has great success it's an
easy read it's an enjoyable read it's a
fun read I like the human component so
much I want to thank you for writing it
and I thank you for sharing your time
today on the end of the impossible
podcast yeah thanks for having me any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent guest
newest book send a screenshot of your
review to info at imagine UCSD edu we
appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination UCSD edu find us on
Twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
YouTube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c clarke center for human imagination in
the division of physical sciences at the
University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco